the rollout for the new playstation plus
has been revealed god of war gets
another tiny update and more
sony has announced the release dates for
the new version of playstation plus and
it'll be here pretty soon in a blog post
sony said the new playstation plus will
debut in asian markets but not japan
starting late may with release in japan
the americas and europe to follow
throughout june now before we get into
the dates keep in mind that these are
not set in stone instead they are target
dates for when sony aims to launch the
new version of the subscription service
asian markets excluding japan are
targeted for may 23rd japan on june 1st
the americas on june 13th and europe on
june 22nd adding to this sony announced
that one of the perks of the new
playstation plus cloud streaming access
at the platinum tier is expanding to
more regions for a total of 30. the
newly confirmed markets include bulgaria
croatia
czech republic greece hungary malta
poland republic of cyprus romania
slovakia and slovenia for more on the
new playstation plus changes check out
our other videos playstation plus versus
xbox game pass and new playstation plus
feels boring compared to xbox game pass
in other sony news playstation is
finally joining the cross play party for
borderlands 3. that's right gearbox
software has officially announced that
borderlands 3 will soon have full
cross-play support across all platforms
sometime this spring with the update
players across pc xbox and playstation
consoles as well as streaming through
stadia can connect and play together
previously all platforms except
playstation supported cross play in
borderlands 3. just ahead of the launch
of tiny tina's wonderlands a game with
full cross-play support for all
platforms gearbox's randy pittsford said
it was inevitable that borderlands 3
would add this next back when
borderlands 3 originally launched in
2019 it was revealed that sony
apparently blocked crossplay for reasons
it never disclosed sony has historically
not been the strongest supporter of
crossplay during the epic vs apple trial
for example documents submitted to the
court revealed that sony required
developers to pay a royalty fee when
adding cross-play functionality to their
games luckily one of sony's biggest
upcoming releases god of war ragnarok
doesn't have to worry about cross play
at all earlier this week sony santa
monica gave a brief update on ragnarok
but the studio did not flat out say the
game remains on track for release in
2022 that being the case some wondered
if the ps4 ps5 game had shifted to next
year but it hasn't someone on twitter
asked ragnarok animation director bruno
velasquez for reassurance that the game
was still on track for release in 2022
and the last quest confirmed quote
ragnarok is coming this year so unless
he tweeted this from a time machine
somewhere in the future i think we're
safe to conclude he's definitely talking
about 2022 when he says this year have
you played god of war 2018 if not why
you better have some good excuse like
scared of bald men now for the rest of
you let me know what you're playing this
weekend follow me on twitter at devonta
chisholm and i'll catch you next week
you